previously on tv since i didn't realize
you wanted to sleep with my mother
walter
oh this is awkward i'm gonna walk uh i'm
gonna walk this situation off and i will
see you later
you need to believe in the impossible
can you do that condescending narration
condensation
also need to believe in the impossible
do cows climb trees and shout expletives
at the passing parade of pillowcases
below
no the answer is not man everything 14
years ago sure was
orangier my whole life i've been running
usually from bullies i love how kid
versions of our favorite superheroes i
mean
superheroes always make coincidental
wardrobe choices that match their future
super suits
i wasn't fast enough fast enough kid
gets in a fight at school and his first
thought is he wants to be faster man we
sure are laying on this backstory
contrivance pretty thick within the
first minute aren't we he was running an
errand for me
barry did you give me what i asked for
geez captain joe you couldn't have made
that cover up any more obvious if you
added a monty python style wink wink
nudge nudge at the end of that sentence
csi central city that's a pretty clever
way to show investigation and deduction
is what i said to myself when i saw
bbc's sherlock do this exact same thing
four years before the flash even debuted
also 12 inches with asymmetrical tread
were the exact instructions my college
girlfriend gave me when she asked me to
get her new getaway cars and mustang
shelby gt500 oh come on even if that is
true barry would have to have the entire
tire database memorized to be able to
pull that kind of info off the top of
his head
also who knew the world's greatest
detective was in the justice league but
wasn't batman
tickle excrement animal i'd guess jeez i
hope so
my dad gave me that pen before he died
and yet you carry it around with you for
daily work and you didn't say anything
until just this moment because poop
jokes
dc comics can entertainment please stop
with the whole transparency agenda we
don't want transparent phones tablets or
computer screens and we especially don't
want transparent dry erase boards it's
completely impractical as evidenced by
that unreadable and pointless equation
in the corner here it works nicely for
the aesthetics of film but in real life
would be a nightmare
the fecal matter i found on the street
it was cow manure which contained traces
of oxytetracycline well it wouldn't be
an arrow over a show without a healthy
dose of [ __ ]
did you find proof of the impossible in
starling city or did you just
make my dad mad for no reason why are
these protesters completely silent is
this how people protest in central city
by putting together signs and then
standing there silently bobbing them up
and down
there is nothing that i want more than
for you to meet the right person that
totally
loves and adores you for the amazing guy
that you are geez this is way too early
for a will they or won't they cliche i
don't even know if they do or don't i'm
just saying it's setting it up hard from
the very
beginning my name is harrison wells i
like this harrison wells guy i'm glad
he's gonna be a part of this show for
seasons to come and
not relegated to a series of more and
more ridiculous and tiresome clones of
himself good thing that would never
happen trust me
that future will be here faster than you
think and i trust this show will also
not
end the speed puns anytime soon hey my
laptop it's about my dissertation
and what better time for a purse
snatching than a ted talk on a super
duper physics doohickey i hear all the
petty criminals hang out at these events
please please or do you want to find out
the hard way you're not faster than a
bullet it's almost like everyone in this
universe has been coached to use only
idioms that involve speed
oh look my remote control has the word
fast on it too
[Applause]
i could get used to this also i want to
find out why this police officer was
just hanging out in what appears to be a
rather desolate area on the other side
of this fence
he's a transfer from keystone started a
few weeks ago
eddie thawne so thawne is a keystone cop
i know this is a shout out to the
original comics but i just need to say
it again
he's literally a keystone cop okay i
feel better now sure the headline is
very clearly about the murder but for
some reason the entirety of the first
two paragraphs of this article are about
how their son thinks the dad is innocent
it's almost like evan gibson the city
desk staff news reporter was a pseudonym
for a writer of a tv show about a
superhero origin story of a boy who saw
his mother kill
i got a plate to catch what does that
have to do with anything was that
supposed to be a clever line
information the police needed seriously
you're in the middle of a gunfight with
the ccpd and you yell out i've got a
plane to catch were you worried they
wouldn't understand why you were running
away
officials are now trying to shut down
the particle accelerator dude i know
this is the flash but
this is happening quick i mean the first
10 minutes have shown a sherlock-like
ability for barry
an introduction of a particle
accelerator that's apparently better
than concern a neck shooting a raging
flirtation a purse snatching
and what am i missing oh yeah barry's
mom died in a flash tornado
jesus show pace yourself good thing for
the beauty of this shot that all these
containers of various liquids that barry
allen has needlessly sitting on his
shelves just happen to be a variety of
well-lit fluorescent colors huh get it
because nine months is the approximate
length of human gestation he's being
reborn
you see except actual human gestation is
closer to 10 months so
suck it on the nose metaphors i'm cisco
ramon
she's caitlin dr snow if this show works
it's because of the casting of these
three
cisco kate and barry are so likable
together here it's ridiculous and grant
gustin is so good he might be the only
tv super who could pull off the dash to
the big screen i mean his freaking name
is even a perfect superhero secret
identity grant gustin it's alliterative
and everything
lightning gave me abs fairy would be
great at tv since
also the cw keeps its skin claws perfect
score intact because how are we supposed
to know if we can trust them until we've
seen them without shirts on the
distracting thing about these obvious
comic book easter eggs is that they
aren't subtle enough for the casual
viewer to ignore if you haven't been
studying your villains
of central city flash cards you're
wondering what this whole grodd license
plate means and how it's going to come
into play later in the episode
hint it doesn't detective west and his
daughter gave me permission to bring you
here where
we were able to stabilize you but this
isn't a hospital facility so i believe
it would take more than family
permission for a move like that to be
made this is a robbery
well would you look at that the bad guys
introduced in the first half of the
episode are robbing a bank on the exact
day that barry comes out of his coma
will wonders never cease
no seriously will they it's a little
snug superhero initially wears a
terribly embarrassing suit for the first
super experience cliche
my once promising career in
bioengineering is over once promising
career what are you 18
23 i swear these actors are so young
that all this adulting conversation
feels like five-year-olds playing house
or
doctor or something so this blank
expression kind of feels like the way to
go danielle deadpanabaker man whenever
these new dc shows are pitched there
must be only two questions afterwards
does it have narration and can we add
some flashbacks
sounds like one of those wide world
weird cases very successfully you're not
obsessed
yes you haven't read his blog well he
wouldn't have written anything for the
last nine months so why would anyone
just because you cut away from it don't
think i'm letting you get away with a
classic case of zoom in enhance you
merely adopted the zoom in enhance
i was born in it what happened out there
today you're moving pretty well and then
something caused you to lose focus
how would wells even know that barry has
established he doesn't know how to stop
and i'm assuming that's why the water
barrels were there in the first place so
why would he think he was distracted
when the exact thing they planned for
happened they arrested my dad
he's still sitting in iron heights for
her murder they should know all this
though right they've had the last nine
months to become barry allen experts
jeez barry stalker much isn't central
city a big
place holy [ __ ] how incompetent is this
police department barry's already had to
stop a cop from having his gun stolen
in the jail mind you and now this squad
guard just crashes willy-nilly into any
road-sized structure i get that mardan
can create a storm but he's not
indestructible right how did he get out
of that car so quickly after the crash
and have the ability to walk away
[Laughter]
and when i just confronted martin the
street was instantly
enveloped and fall i mean that's one way
to say it but instantly
considering he clearly made a motion to
create it and then it started emanating
directly from him why is barry acting
like this is still some kind of theory
your dad killed your mother barry i am
sorry son are you
because you actually sound angry and
towards a guy who saw his mom die when
he was a child
even if you believe it was all a coping
mechanism i'm gonna go ahead and say
yelling at people for how they process
their childhood trauma is the chicken
soup for the [ __ ] definition of how
to handle this
i have done my best to take care of you
since that night and i have never asked
for anything in return not even a thank
you this show should really be called
expositional arguing life on the street
but what i do ask
now is that you for once in your life
see things as they
are wait isn't barry like a forensics
expert didn't they use his sherlockian
deduction to find mardon in the first
place the hell does this show want to be
right now if i didn't know better i'd
say that's clyde
martin yeah that's similar right officer
though you may want to ask the witness
who worked with the sketch artist if
they maybe were just describing this
exact mugshot i mean it's an identical
picture down to the strands of hair over
his left eye i haven't seen copying this
blatant since robin thicke and pharrell
heard a marvin gaye song they liked
metahumans that's what we are calling
them we were going to go with the
mutants but the lawyers stepped in
none of the cops noticed that there was
a young boy just kind of wandering
around a murder scene before he got all
the way in
kneeled next to the body and uncovered
it so the flashburn just affects the
jacket what about the rest of his
clothes or his shoes
arrow cameo arrow so why come to me more
importantly how come to me
or something my point is we know barry
took a field trip to starling city
before he was all meta and stuff but how
and why would he have
ever known who arrow actually was what's
that you say this is all explained in
season 2 episode 8 of some other tv show
that i have to have watched to
understand this one ah well in that case
here's 20 extra sins for the homework
i don't think that bolt of lightning
struck you very i think it chose you oh
no pretty sure it struck him cool cool
not cool
something i've been playing with it's
designed to replace the turnouts
firefighters traditionally wear
good things cisco was working on
something for firefighters and not say
doctors or the police heat and abrasive
resistance so it should withstand your
moving at high velocity speed
and even though i just said that i
invented it for firefighters i designed
it with a circle on the chest in case
you ever might need a superhero logo or
something
i'm not saying martin is alive but if he
was this is the last place him and his
brother hit up and i'm saying it at full
volume because the element of surprise
is overrated the night of the storm
after star labs blew after our plane
went down and i woke up on the ground
alive villain's position so is good
timing also one of barry's superpowers
if it keeps up this could become an f5
tornado really because it's within about
10 feet from a couple of trees here and
it's moving them around less than a
medium-sized thunderstorm would i'm not
sure show knows how to tornado properly
what if i unravel it sure but couldn't
you also just run the [ __ ] in there
tackle weather underground and zoom him
right over to the police station or hell
the middle of kansas
when i looked at you all i saw was
another potential victim of my hubris
you mean like how lots of people might
die because you felt like now was a good
time to monologue instead of just giving
him the instruction he needs to make
this work those kind of victims of your
hubris
i didn't think there was anyone else
like me if you're the flash why would
you ever wait to do anything as soon as
he points that gun wouldn't you just go
take it from him immediately
you believing me is all i need well
having a pack of cigarettes to keep
topeka bob from visiting my cell later
on tonight you got a pack of cigarettes
why is it shaped like a lightning bolt
so it's not boring
oh and also i'm just spitballing here
because he got his powers by being
struck by lightning squarey alone puts
caitlyn straight into the lead of the
dumb questions game
my name is barry allen
my whole life i've been running i just
felt like running
getaway cars and mustang shelby gt500
are you sure i'm positive
or maybe he got taken for a ride
do you know what happens to a toad when
it's struck by lightning the same thing
that happens to everything else don't
look at explosions
cool cool cool cool
i have been and we shall be
your friend